- If I was telling a
kid right now, I'd say,
brother unless, brother and sister,
unless there's a super
serious thing you can
get a degree in that you can you exchange
for green rectangles, don't go.
'Cause half the people going in right now
are getting degrees that mean nothing.
(serious music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and this
is "The Rubin Report".
Reminder, everybody,
subscribe to rubinreport.com
if you wanna get all our videos early
and totally ad-free.
And more importantly, joining me today
is a stand up comic and host
of "Dennis Miller Plus One",
on the RT Network,
as well as the "Dennis
Miller Option" podcast.
Dennis Miller, I've already
said your name three times.
- What's up, Rubes?
- Welcome
to "The Rubin Report".
- Beautiful pad, here, man.
I'm trying to read.
You can tell a man by his books--
- How am I doing?
- And his tchotchkes.
I see you're a Carlin fan,
which I find endearing.
- Of course.
- A little Steven Pinker, NBA.
I think your detractors would say
this indicates you're moving rightward
towards John Birch participation.
on the the bottom.
(Dave laughing)
Where do you have the map centered out?
And that odd confluence
between South America and,
or the globe, I should say,
South America and Africa
where it's split up.
And now, I have a theory.
It looks like they were
together at one point--
- Yes.
- And they split apart,
and obviously the west coast
of Africa with Ivory Coast,
Liberia is the most contentious
place on the planet,
and I think that's a
sudden hard drive tremble
from way back where a guy
went out into his yard
in Liberia once and said,
Honey, what's this crack?
And then two weeks later--
- Next thing--
- It was another continent.
- I've oft wondered
how Pangaea split.
(Dennis laughing)
Now I have a little--
- There you go.
- Yeah, I'm giving you
a little something of everything here,
'cause we got lefties, we got righties.
Look, I got an American flag
in the control room over there.
- And I love the map.
I always love to have a map in my studio
to feel situated.
- Yeah.
So you got two shows, you've
done a bajillion things.
I said here right before,
I'm not even gonna use notes.
I try not to really look at my notes
when I talk to most guests anyway,
but I thought I'd just sit
down and see what happens.
You kinda just need to be wound up
and then you go, right?
- Well, you know what?
But I tell you as I get older,
I need to be wound up and let go less.
I'm just, listen, it's contentious now.
I was more of a, I don't wanna use the,
it's a tired term, fire brin,
but I was more willing
to engage, lock antlers,
when I was young.
I don't think people are gonna
change their minds anymore.
I don't wanna be the carnival barker
on some freak show.
People were split.
We'll find out where we go
each way at each election.
In between, it's gonna be contentious.
At age 66, I don't wanna wake up every day
and fight with people
about stuff they're not
gonna change their mind on anyway.
So when I get going, I
like to put on a good show.
You're Spanky and our
gang, let's put on a show,
but I don't need to get
going as much anymore.
- So you're like an evolved
political satirist or something.
- I just, I used to dig the game
when you could budge somebody.
An angster.
I didn't need them to come over.
I never thought that you're gonna talk
to somebody and they were
gonna desert their core beliefs
and come over your way.
But at least you could see them mulling.
I think mulling's gone.
I could see hmms gone.
It's just now, everybody's dug in.
- I'm trying, man, I'm trying over here.
- Nah, I appreciate it.
But like I said, you're
in your 40s, right?
I would have probably
fought to fought more then.
But I'm telling you what,
you seem like just the
time we talked before,
you seem like a smart enough cat
that somewhere down the road
I can't see you fighting it
into the barn.
Seem to be loving, a beautiful family
in the picture out
here, got a great place.
You're kicking ass and
taking names, career wise.
Yeah, you should do it now.
But at some point, the harvest is,
what are you gonna do?
I'm into getting up and
reading, taking a hike,
having a good meal,
appreciating the fact I married
the most beautiful, witty,
charming girl I ever met,
adoring my sons, watching some baseball
and then reading as I fall off to sleep.
- Is that a tough thing,
though, for a comic
to have to face?
- No, not for me.
- No, but do you think
for most comics, that's,
like, you almost have to fear that?
- I don't know.
- Do you fear the okayness,
'cause you won't have the fuel?
- It's a comedian, it's a job.
Yeah, I was never very,
I don't view show business as some
Sword from the Stone moment
where you're anointed.
It's a job.
I grew up in Pittsburgh.
And my job, what I was good at was,
I would think jokes up.
And then I'd try to give those jokes
to somebody else to do
and I found I didn't
have the ego for that.
Once I saw somebody do a joke I thought,
up on "The Tonight Show"
and Carson laughing,
I thought, "I'm not built for this,
"I better become the unlikely conduit."
But I've never thought of myself
as the Silver Surfer comedian.
- Yeah.
- And so no, I don't have
any moment pangs or anything,
oh, I wish I was in the frame.
It never was like that
when I was in the frame.
- Were you always political?
'Cause I think, I--
- No, once you get that job
on "SNL", you have to become political.
- Yeah, so weren't political before that?
- I used to be a prop comic.
I remember working with,
I was never quite Carrotopian, but I--
- Is that an actual word?
I think that's probably
in the dictionary now.
That's depressing.
- I did props when I first started,
'cause I thought, visually, that way.
But then I remember I
couldn't fit the props
in the overhead.
I had slight props.
And then I thought, "I'm not
gonna wait a half an hour
"at a revolving carousel
"for a toilet seat--
- Right, for some inflatable.
- "I could put on my head
and say alas poor turd".
So I ditched out on that,
started writing jokes.
Like I said, sold a
couple to other comedians,
saw them do them and score
with them and thought,
"I've gotta be the guy".
So like I said, it was very,
I didn't have a whoosh,
whoosh thing about stand up.
I remember thinking, "Okay,
this is a good career."
Kind of a decision.
- So when you get
the "Weekend Update"
situation, the "SNL" situation,
then it sort of like, it was political.
What year did you start at "SNL"?
- Somewhere in the '80s.
- Somewhere in the--
- That's what I mean, though.
I'm not doing that deliberately.
- It's funny, yeah.
- I just,
I remember I was--
- Maybe in,
like, '89 or something?
'Cause I'm trying to remember.
'Cause you on "SNL", that class was like
my formative comedy year class.
- Yeah.
- So I was, like,
12, 13, around then, and I think,
I think maybe like '89
or something like that.
- Well some people choose--
- Was it even before that?
- To think of themselves
as comedic visionaries.
I choose to think of ourself as
ushering kids through puberty.
We were the, if you were 12 or 13 (laughs)
that's all we were.
That was our 15 minutes
off from jerking off.
- Yeah, but you guys did it.
- "Weekend Update".
- See, I made it out okay.
- But I remember I was in Baltimore,
and I had auditioned for
"SNL" maybe a month before.
And then I remember they picked the cast.
"USA Today" had the picture of them.
I wasn't in it, I was still in Baltimore.
And I was so tough at that point,
because on your way up
you have to be tough.
You did stand up in New York 12 years.
I was a gladiator.
And I remember seeing that picture.
I didn't have a crestfallen thing.
Ah, I think I came close to that.
All right, keep going.
Then I was up doing "Letterman".
And somebody came into the
"Letterman" dressing room
and said, listen, Lorne Michaels wants
to see on you eight, or no,
17, where his office was.
And I said, gees, I knew something was,
he's not calling me down to revisit me
to tell me why he didn't give it to me.
- Yeah, you're really not getting it.
- But I'm thinking maybe I get a shot
on it as a comedian or something.
Like Steven Wright would come on,
Sam once in awhile.
So I went down, I knew it
was gonna be something good,
but then I walked in and I remember,
it's one of those moments
that stick in your head.
Lorne sits at the end of the thing,
he's got one of those green domed glasses,
lights on his desk that gives it that
Arthur Conan Doyle feel.
And he's got the quarter glasses on,
reading scripts or something.
And over his shoulder is
the Empire State Building.
And I remember it being,
like, red, white, and blue.
And it wasn't 4th of July or anything,
but he looks up and he
goes, "Hey, Dennis Miller."
And I go, "Hey, Lorne."
And he says, "How would you
like to do 'Weekend Update'"?
And I said, "I'd like that a lot."
And he said, "I'll see you
tomorrow at around 11."
I said, "All right, sir."
I walked out and I remember thinking,
I'm not a big drinker,
but I remember thinking,
"I'm gonna go get four
fingers of something brown
"on the rocks and knock this down,
"'cause this is pivotal."
And that was magical.
I don't wanna act like I'm
sitting over here like Rasputin.
I'm talking about stand up,
I was kinda step-by-step, Maginot line,
move it six inches, fall
back four, move it four.
But when that happened,
I remember thinking,
"All right, take some
mental Polaroids here,
"don't be blase about this,
"'cause that's it's
own defense mechanism."
This is a big deal.
Chevy Chase did this.
You're gonna do it now.
Enjoy it 'til you either become
a success or get whacked.
So I did enjoy it along the way.
I took all those moments.
And the first time you sit in that seat
and they count you down.
I just thought, all right, I might go out
but I'm going out on my shield here.
- So even though you
weren't purely political,
they pegged you for that.
Is that what you wanted?
- I did some topical stuff.
- Did you wanna do more?
- I wanted any hook.
I'm not a character guy.
I used to try to stay out
of the "SNL" sketches.
'Cause when you're with geniuses,
Carvey's a comedic genius, Lovett's,
sketchwise, a genius, Phil,
the ultimate clue guy.
I mean the only guy, I never thought I'd
see a guy like Denny, and Phil
got in the realm with him,
and always thought,
well, this is a serious,
Mike Myers comes in.
So you got four leads there
who could kill the ball.
I'm the fifth guy in a sketch,
I'm the bartender saying,
here's your gimlet,
and yet, I gotta be there
blocking it for 3 1/2 hours.
So I used to go around
and say to the writers
when they wrote me in,
I'd say, don't put me in.
I wanna be like the DH.
I wanna pick a rock song,
swing the weighted bat
down the tunnel, come out and
hit the ball for 10 minutes.
- And by the end you had that, right?
- Yeah, it was a groovy job.
And I used to, I've probably been
in around a dozen sketches over the years.
And they were ones where I thought,
"oh, this is good.
"I should stay in this
'cause I wanna see this
"when I get older."
"It's a Wonderful Life", the next chapter.
You knew when something
was gonna be a big hit.
But by and large I was really happy
to have just "Weekend Update".
- I'm sure you've been
asked this a million times,
but what do you think it is about "SNL",
or the ages, or the collection,
or the level of talent of all the people
that there's so much tragedy
around the cast members?
- I'd have to back and study that.
Is there?
- Well, I mean deaths,
and drug use, I mean, well I guess,
drug use, drug use is
just Hollywood, but yeah.
Yeah.
- John, Chris.
I don't know, I'd like to
see the actuary tables.
I always hear this thing.
- Yeah, oh so you don't even
think that there's anything?
- I met a lot of healthy people there.
There were a few guys
who I coulda met working
in a hardware store where I'd know--
- That had it rough, too.
- Reading about him someday.
(both laughing)
- All right, fair enough.
I didn't think you were gonna say that.
- Well, and I just say I
don't remember it that way.
- Something about the
pressure of live, maybe?
I don't know, something.
- You know,
all that stuff seems contrived to me.
- Hmm.
- You're working
as an entertainer in some way,
and all of a sudden you're on
the best entertainment vehicle
for young people in the
world, quite frankly.
Now, you can spend your days
sitting in a room thinking,
"Oh, my stomach hurts, I'm schpilkis,
"and I gotta go get loaded",
or you can just get on
with it and have a blast.
And it is scary.
And there were weeks it felt
horrible when you'd go badly.
That's any gig.
But that whole crash and burn thing,
it's so far from that.
If somebody would have said to me,
at the end of the day
this is gonna cause you
to do yourself in, I'd have
said I'm not taking the job.
It's not that magical kingdom to me.
- What would you have done?
If it wasn't for comedy?
- I would have liked
to maybe be a shrink.
- Yeah?
- I don't know.
Maybe not anymore because things that used
to interest me about people,
their psychological tales now have turned
into blatant whining.
(Dave laughing)
So I don't think it'd be
a good shrink for today
to have people come in and say,
I got in a fight when
I was in fourth grade.
And you go, you're fuckin' 70.
Wake up.
But at the time I thought
that might be interesting.
What else did I wanna do?
I never even thought like that.
But if I said anything, I'd say a shrink.
- Yeah, so what do you make of the way
everything's changing right now?
You're doing a show on RT.
You got a podcast.
Everyone's got a podcast.
So you've shifted around.
You were on cable news for years
doing your thing with O'Reilly.
What do you make of the way
just the media landscape
is changing, and how
everyone gets everything
in a different way?
- Well, I'll tell you what.
It might be my inner pragmatist,
but I never even say
everybody's got a podcast.
I'd say there's tens of thousands
of people have a podcast.
You probably whittle
that down to a thousand
that are even worth
getting into the business
and seeing if you dig it.
You probably get down to 100
that really are completely
in sync with the PITA principle.
They're maxing it out,
whatever talent they have.
You get down to around two
dozen that are killing it.
I think you're in that two dozen.
- Thanks.
- So I don't disparage it
with that everybody has a podcast.
Until everybody has a podcast, no.
There's a bunch of people
throwing scat up against the wall.
There's a bunch of people trying it.
I would try it, too, if I was young
and I didn't know if it was talented.
It's a great thing.
It's like you used to jump
up at an open mic night,
why not do a podcast?
But the simple fact is,
I view the attrition rate
as much the same as any other
aspect of show business.
- Yeah.
- I mean,
look at it, brother, you're killing it.
And for me to just say
everybody's got one,
no, you got one.
- Well, I guess,
yeah, I guess, I'll take the--
- Well,
that's what they think.
- I'll take the compliment.
Well, I guess the--
- It's math.
- Right, right, so the
barrier to entry is low.
But yeah, it doesn't
mean you've got something
that's really cookin'.
- Barrier to entry
should always be low.
- Yeah.
- Anybody can jump in and
try anything they want.
Show business is no magic,
or I've said magic kingdom,
no exalted higher plane.
It's showbiz, it's you going
out to strangers and saying,
let me either make you
think, cry, or laugh.
That's all it is at the end of the day.
People have always been
interested in that.
Town criers.
People, "Seventh Seal", Joey
Rod doing the puppet shows
to the paupers.
I don't know, to me it seems
like a hard drive issue.
I'm sure there was somebody
sitting around the mud pit
way back when, when in Kubricktown
when somebody came in with a
femur and cracked the other,
and I'm sure there was some guy trying
to do a rye rejoinder to the other ape
having their head crushed in. (laughs)
Folks, I wanna tell you it's
been around since day one.
So I don't know, I was drawn to,
to me, it should be an
easy point of entry.
It shouldn't be that high a bar.
It's just you trying to entertain people.
- Yeah, so what really
interests you these days?
Like, what's really exciting?
- I'm trying
to read everything PG Wodehouse ever read.
I hike.
Let's see, I'm trying
to teach myself to not,
active fame's pretty, it
comes at you fast and furious.
Speaking of Kubrick, it reminds me
of Keir Dullea at the end
of "2001" where it's just.
So you can't always be--
- That's what the whole world
feels like right now, doesn't it?
- Yeah, you're in a chute,
man, a wind tunnel test,
and it's flying.
- Yeah.
- So you can't always be lucid about it.
I think that if you're on
the planet for 85 years,
the front end of that 20,
and there's guys like Eddie who beat it,
but usually 'til 20 you're anonymous.
And the last 10 years you're probably,
so 30 of those out, you
got a half a century.
If you get any part of
that where you're famous
and you're actually
seated at a nice table,
where strangers come up to
you and say, you've won.
(Dave laughing)
And to try to think,
this is the way life should be, it isn't.
So when you say, what are you doing,
I'm trying to, what do they call it?
Mindfulness.
But that's almost falling
into its own cliche.
I'm trying to be aware of
what a great run I had,
and I might be in the (speaking
foreign language) of that,
and that's fine.
But you can see when you
even mention it to people
where you say, I don't
think I was hot as I was.
I don't know if I'll
ever be that hot again,
people kinda wince and go, oh, I think.
I mean it sincerely.
I think the examined life is everything.
And I wanna examine my life.
I wanna feel legit here as I,
hopefully another 30 years,
get it into the barn,
I wanna analyze what part of me,
which was a shy kid, ends up
getting braggadocios enough
to try showbiz, hits the ball hard,
and I think I inhabited
that plane pretty well.
And now, not as hot,
I wanna inhabit that plane just as well.
It's equally valid.
I--
- I love the answer.
I mean, that's as honest
as it can get, I think.
- Well, I like that.
I never predicated on me riding
into the sunset with the key light on me.
Listen, you have your moment.
It's hard to, I don't know,
I don't know far you're into it now,
you told me you did 12 years of stand up,
so I know you've got some
hard riding under your belt.
- I stood on a lot of street corners.
- And you're killing it now.
But I don't know that humans are built
to keep it up, 'til they're,
all of a sudden you're Larry Sanders
doing the show at seven and going,
I don't mean Gary, I mean--
- Yeah, no, you mean Larry.
- Yeah, I mean Larry Sanders going back
and laying in bed and watching the repeat.
That four hours between live show
and watching it on the East Coast feed,
there's just no life.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think about it sometimes,
even though I'm sorta right
in the thick of it right now.
It's like when things change, or I change,
or family expands, or
whatever it is that, like,
will I wanna do it at this level,
or you deal with a certain amount of hate,
or any of those things, you know?
- Well, you'll only find out--
- There's only one way
to find out.
- I don't wanna sound like I'm
on "The Bachelor" on your trip,
but all I know is it was never my trip
to take it all the way.
And at some point I remember thinking,
it's like base camps on Everest.
And all of a sudden
you're planting a flag,
you're thinking, "How the
hell did this happen?"
And then all of a sudden
when you're at six base camp
and you're boiling water with the Sherpa,
they say, we're not gonna let
you make the climb tomorrow,
you go, okay, I'm gonna get cozy in here
with Tenzig Norgay the fourth. (laughs)
I'm fine with that.
They start moving me down the
mountain, I had a big run.
- Do you think most people
are afraid of that, sort of?
And that is why everyone is kinda nuts?
Like, we're all sort of afraid of trying
to figure out what would
make us actually happy?
So we get obsessed with
whatever the news cycle is,
or whatever else?
- I don't wanna give you pat answer,
then I turn into the
guy in the second row--
- Don't be that guy.
- At a Tony Robbins thing.
I'm not as scared shitless
of anonymity as some people.
If I fall back into that,
I'm gonna examine that in the
same way I examined being,
I don't know,
I remember the first two
years of being famous.
Maybe this was a tell.
And when I say famous,
folks, where's the camera?
I don't wanna sound like an asshole.
I'm just saying you end up famous.
I remember spending two years up front
not even being able to focus on it
because I would notice it, I
would be too pleased with it,
the pragmatic side of myself
would castigate the side
that was too pleased with it,
the other side would come in and defend me
against the mean side.
Say, okay, come on, he's just got,
and I'd say, I'm spending 12
hours a day figuring this out.
And at some point I remember,
it's like an algebraic
equation, cancel terms out.
It just is.
It doesn't mean anything, in a weird way.
Are you a good dad?
Are you a good friend?
And I'm not saying I am.
As far as friends, I'm a little distant.
But I'm just saying there are so many ways
to shoot your life through.
And when you're in it, it
takes all your attention,
'cause you gotta stay laser focused.
I always view fame like it's a party.
All of a sudden you're outside
and it's like those old
Warner Brothers cartoons
where the house has got notes coming out.
♪ Da, da, da, da, na, na, na ♪
All of a sudden you get in the door
and you, like, stay against the wall
and it's a Saurti's caricature.
Every, it's like a last supper of fame
and you're pressed against the wall
looking at it, like, holy shit.
You edge into the party,
and then all of a sudden,
the sweet spot is halfway into the party.
And then you, like, have two seconds there
and then you realize half the
party's happening behind you
and you don't know who's gonna
"Y tu Brute" in the sauna.
And eventually you get
through to the other wall
and go to the bathroom.
So at some point I always
had that in my head
from the first moment that I got it.
And so I'm not disappointed.
It always seemed to have a
natural shelf life to me.
- Yeah, so I don't wanna do
the greatest hits with you
'cause I wanna do sorta
where you're at now.
But so when you, then,
start doing "O'Reilly",
and then suddenly people are going,
wait a minute, this is the
"SNL Weekend Update" guy.
He's like this sort of,
like, hip, cool, lib kinda.
Suddenly you're on "O'Reilly".
- I was as hip or cool,
or as not hip and cool, I was the same.
- But the optics of it.
Now, suddenly, wait a minute,
this doesn't make sense.
He was on "SNL" and now
he's on evil Fox News.
This is not my opinion,
this is just sorta like--
- Yeah, well, people have to
figure their own thing out.
- Yeah, but did you fear that at all?
Or even, none of it?
- No, no.
- Interesting.
- Listen, man, I was on
the number one rated show
on cable, I think, Bill for 20 years.
I was doing six minutes a week.
It was a beautiful gig.
We'd go out on the road once a week,
or once a month, we'd sell
10,000 seats. (laughs)
- Crazy.
Could you believe that?
Could he believe it?
- We definitely were a one
plus one equals three thing.
'Cause on my own I'd probably,
at that point draw two.
I don't know what Billy was
drawing, but probably two.
But you put us together and
the Mutt and Jeff of it,
it always reminded me of that scene
in the Chaplin movie, not
saying we were Chaplinesque,
where Charlie puts his foot behind his leg
and he kicks the guy who's
working the border guard thing,
or the guy at Ellis Island
kicks him in the butt.
I was doing that to O'Reilly.
And the key moment in
that relationship was
when I told Bill, you're
like a big Mick beat cop,
Irish beat cop, where
you're spinning that stick,
everybody's scared shitless of you,
and I'm gonna call you
Billy instead of Bill.
That why was a great move.
Because all of a sudden the power,
the monolith is being poked fun
at by the Mutt and Jeff guy.
And it was cool.
That's why it worked together is 'cause
I could make him laugh, an
unguarded laugh periodically,
and I could poke fun at
him, I could call him Billy,
I could wear shorts on his show,
which I'd put my leg up and
he'd say, do you not have pants?
All that worked.
And that's why--
- Were you doing
a lot of those hits from home?
Did you have a home
situation, or were you going
into Fox affiliators often?
- No.
I went over to this place
called the Rubin Studios.
No, I, we did it up in Santa
Barbara in another studio.
We were always on a split screen.
It was so funny, until we
started going on the road
people would say, you and Bill,
like we're Hope and Crosby.
I said, I've met him twice. (laughs)
We're always on split screen.
But over the years, I'll tell you what.
I'm relatively ill-at-ease socially.
I don't know what that is, I
don't wanna make it precious.
Bill, I think if you could
watch him over the years,
he's a little--
- Are you?
'Cause off camera you seem
exactly the same to me--
- Well--
- Where, no, but there's
plenty of comics, I know exactly
what you're talking about.
There's a lot of comics that are weird,
have eye contact stuff,
don't wanna touch anybody,
and then the second the camera goes on,
and bam, they're there.
But from the little bit
we just did our thing,
I didn't catch that.
- Well, I do know
that I don't go to a lot of social events
and stuff like that when I'm working.
I meet a Hale fellow while I'm at,
I like to say hi and be
normal, I'm in a cat's place.
But I'm not a real social
guy and he isn't either.
So when you put the two of us together,
I was enamored at that part of O'Reilly.
And I sometimes didn't
understand his brusk manner,
and I something thought,
"Why is he beating his drum
"to that degree", when
I'd watch him on the show.
And Bill, if you're seeing this,
I'm not, you know, I'm telling you,
I saw that cat do stuff for soldiers,
kids who'd been abused,
Haitians after storms,
yeah, sometimes the, in the
way that doesn't matter,
the topical stuff, I sometimes
found him equally ill-at-ease
as I am, but walking the walk,
that cat gave a lot of
money to a lot of people.
And I don't know his personal life.
People say, what about?
I go, do you really think?
Oh, okay, so that's my
relationship with O'Reilly.
I'm gonna call him and talk about dating,
or whatever the hell's going on.
It's not my life with him.
We went out on the road and I saw him
do a lot of good things
for a lot of people.
And guess what?
I felt no need to know,
to probe the underbelly
of Bill O'Reilly, or find out
what really makes him tick,
and he felt no need to find that.
That being said, I did
see him do enough things
over the years that I
find him an honorable man.
- Yeah, what do you think about the way
that we take out people these days?
You don't have to make it
about him, specifically,
but just generally.
Now, Chris Matthews went out,
and it's just like this endless cascade
of we're just gonna build
people up and crush 'em.
- It gets worse.
Listen, imagine, like, Twitter
during DeKinsey in England.
(Dave laughing)
Imagine how cruel it would be there?
Listen, the rules are clear--
- You mean, it's not worse
than it's ever been?
That's what everyone says every day.
It's worse than it's ever been.
- I think the way that it'll turn this,
yeah, it might be, but I think
the way that'll turn this is
everybody who's in the
public eye should get up
to a joke, a witticism,
a pithy revelation,
and stop it down themselves
and look at the camera and say,
I have something here,
but I'm going to stay out
because I understand the new rules.
And have that happen ad
nauseum for a few years.
And I relate to people how
crazy and/or post-Orwellian
it's gotten as far as jokes,
dialogue, throwaways, cruelty.
Indeed, humans are cruel once in awhile.
The fact that that's
all neutered down now,
I think people should be reminded
that we're missing some
of the texture of life,
walking around like we're in
"Logan's Run" or something.
I don't think it will change for awhile,
because to me, it's the
"Lord of the Flies",
and right now, the uptight
people have the conch,
and they're the ones who are gonna speak.
And therefore, if I'm
sitting there and I get
to a point in the joke where I go,
this puts me where I
have to talk to people
who I disagree with about how bad I am,
I stop often and go, nah,
I'm not gonna say it.
I've tackled myself here.
And if enough of that happens,
people are gonna start to
say, hey, I'm sick of this.
- Yeah, do you have a bunch that you just
wouldn't tell anymore?
- Yeah, sure.
- Like an old favorite
that you're just like--
- Yeah, it's easy.
Listen, when I used to
be on network television,
they told you not to swear.
I found it easy not to swear.
When I'm in Vegas, I
found it easy to say fuck.
When I'm here, I don't know
what the rules are here,
you'll bleep 'em--
- No, we don't bleep.
- Yeah, it's easy.
- What do you wanna say?
Come on.
- No, I don't even want to.
- Let's get you canceled
right now, man, come on.
- I don't even think about it.
But I am saying that yes,
and not so much this
point and oh my career
will be taken, I don't care about that.
I care about having to spend time reacting
to nimrods who, quite frankly,
think second guessing is creativity.
It isn't.
- I love that.
- I like being with creative people.
I like being with people
who say things occasion,
(laughs) I can't believe you said that.
And I don't think it's over then.
Listen, the human fray is cacophonous.
It's like, where was it
written that you're never
gonna hear anything that falls on your,
the aphelia in your ear
and you'll disagree with.
I don't wanna lead that life.
So well, therefore, I'll stop
myself just because I think,
"Christ, who needs the bring down
"of some whiny kid telling
me how I've ruined his day?"
- Yeah, I used to do, there's some,
my old stand up tapes are right there.
And I used to do a joke way back when
that I used to say the n-word.
And it was not to be racist in any way.
It was actually a stupid,
silly "Transformers" reference
that I was imitating a
Transformer and I would say this.
And it would always get
a huge laugh, huge laugh.
I would close with it sometimes.
And then one night I was
onstage at Gotham Comedy Club
on 24th, and the audience
kinda turned on me.
This is like, maybe 2004,
something like that.
And I remember thinking,
"I'm putting that one away".
And I never did it again.
I never liked that feeling,
but I was just like--
- Yeah, some people wanna--
- So this is way
before all that.
- Do a Nantucket sleigh ride
with a bit where they ride at the bottom?
- Yeah.
- It doesn't interest me.
- I'm out to please people.
I like to get laughs.
And at some point, if I have an opinion
and I feel it's worth it, I'll push it in,
even if it draws ire.
But there are others times I
think this isn't good enough
to let all this agita into my life.
The Sturm and Drang's tiresome.
It's so precious to me
that we sit down every day,
and 10 times a day somebody has
to get themselves back and supine.
And I remember when, years ago,
there was a cat who was the general manger
for the Los Angeles Dodgers, Al Campanis.
Do you remember him?
- Yeah, yeah, oh yeah.
- He goes on Ted--
- He was before I was here,
but yeah, I remember him.
- He goes
on "Ted Koppel" one night
and he says something that's,
like, from another generation, racially.
And he's dead.
He's dead.
He's gotta go supplicate for Sharpton,
all that silly game.
- 'Cause Sharpton's so righteous
- Yeah.
And I remember thinking,
when Jackie Robinson
first came up, and he goes
to Montreal and the Dodgers,
and he's playing minor league baseball,
and they gotta sign somebody
to go out with the cat
and ride wing man, I think
Campanis is right there.
I mean, when it came to
real life he's there.
And then later he says something brutish
from the day gone by, and he's over.
And I remember thinking,
"Oh, this is so tedious".
That's the smartest thing
Eric Holder ever said,
although I think he back ended into it.
I don't even think he
meant it the way I took it
when he said, "We're cowards.
"We don't even have chats
about things anymore."
Racial relations, indeed we don't.
And guess what?
You wanna be the first guy in?
- (laughs) Right, exactly.
- Huh, really?
You wanna be over this afternoon trying
to make some sort of lucid nuanced comment
about interactions between human
beings of different colors?
You don't wanna be the first guy in.
You're done.
- It's so funny,
'cause people think it's something new,
but you remember what
took out Howard Cosell
40 years ago?
- Oh yeah, Alvin Garrett.
- That's right, I think
there were two things.
One was about his grandkids.
Remember he, oh, oh, yeah right.
He was the guy that he--
- Alvin Garrett.
- And he called him a
little monkey or something--
- Yeah, and number 46 for--
- Yeah.
- And when you--
- And that's what
he called his grandkids, just
'cause he was jumping around.
He didn't mean it to be racist in any way.
And no one felt he was racist
in any way before that.
- Well, listen, when you,
I think Cosell was just shy
of being an ACLU lawyer.
I used to read Cosell in
"Sport Magazine" once a month,
and he was always at the
vanguard of these movements.
Who was tighter with Ali, for God sakes?
And I saw a special on
Ali the other night,
and it was called, "I Am Ali".
I was reminded, I didn't not appreciate
what he did to Joe Frazier.
Indeed, he missed his own,
he buried his own lead at some point
when he called Frazier
names and stuff like that.
And they have Marvis
Frazier I'm talking about,
how it hurt his father
and hurt his family.
So Ali wasn't perfect, either.
But I watched a guy operate between races
so seamlessly in that thing, I thought,
"There's what we should
all be striving to get to".
Not being complete, Ali was so beautiful.
He was so proud of being
black and beautiful.
And then he'd be with these
old square white people
teasing with 'em, and
he's be with the grannies,
then he'd be with the
children, and I thought,
"Now, here's a guy who gets it."
Gets the human condition.
But we're nowhere near that.
It's so uptight now it's crazy.
- This is total offshoot.
But the references.
Is your brain just designed that way?
- Well, listen, I realize my liabilities,
and I would say one thing
that I would say I'm okay at
is I have a reasonably
deep cultural drawer
and a somewhat quick retrieval system.
When I see those Christmas
stories every year
where the kids are working
in the Amazon disbursement centers
in Minnetola or something
and they got packages coming
at 'em at the speed of light,
you asked me what I wanted
to do for a living earlier.
I think I coulda stood at
the y in the road and said,
okay, emery boards,
headphones, boom, boom, boom.
I think I could have been the,
what do they call it on the kitchen shows?
I think I coulda worked the
pass on cultural referencing.
- Yeah, so you just, but
that was just natural to you
that it was just sort of all there?
Or was that something
that you were going for?
And you were like, oh
that'll be my shtick?
- Well, I think it's a
bit of a monkey trick,
so I don't know where you get that,
nor do I think it's anything that you say
where you get that, but I do remember
on "Saturday Night Live" when I would get
to write the news, and after a few weeks
they had so many holes in
the dyke they let me kinda,
me and Herb Sargent were writing the news.
Other people would write jokes,
but we predominately wrote it.
And I noticed you have to
get actual about yourself.
I couldn't, I needed adrenaline
to be really creative.
And adrenaline came from fear for me.
So I would notice I could not,
occasionally a joke would pop into my head
Monday through Thursday,
but I could see life on the
griddle was what perked me.
So Friday around 4:30 in the
afternoon, it was really funny,
I'd think about Whitney Brown.
And he was so smart.
A little more malevolent
than me, but a brilliant cat.
And we were kinda friends,
but kinda I always thought
if we go to a two-anchor
thing it's Whitney.
So 4:30 in the afternoon on
Friday, I think of Whitney.
And I think, "Brother, you
better get this thing together,
"you better quit this, I can't write."
You do three bad ones of these in a row
you're either out or you're co-hosting.
And that's one thing I'm proud of.
Made it six years and never co-hosted.
So at 4:30.
- Now they all are, right?
For years now, I think.
- I don't know.
- I mean, sure.
- There were guys who did it alone,
but I always look back on that and think,
"Well, that was a good thing."
When you were served your
opportunity, you stepped up to it.
But I remember I had a
big, three big sheets
of paper about that size on
my wall, three different ones.
And it would say "Indignation",
and then the middle one said, "What am I?"
And then the third one
said, "Arcane reference".
(Dave laughing)
And it was like,
it was like a haiku for "Update".
I'd get to a point where
I'd think, oh, (murmuring)
and I'd just look at that
and go, what pisses you off?
Put the see saw in, the fulcrum.
What am I?
The Jetsons' robot maid.
I used to, like, make
it reductio absurdum.
I really got primal at that point.
I felt like I was, like,
like you're a great white.
You might as well heard
the theme from "Jaws"
as you're just swimming
looking for the line.
'Cause I got scared that
I would lose the gig.
But I did have that template in my head.
So maybe that's where the references--
- Yeah, and now it just seems like it's
just sort of built in or something.
Like, it just became.
- Well, I must say that
even before I became a comedian,
goofy stuff would stick in my head.
I don't know.
- Yeah.
But I remember watching one of your,
how many HBO specials have you done?
- Well, I've got nine one-hour specials.
Eight of them were HBO.
- Eight on HBO.
So I'm thinking it must have been
one of your first ones
I remember watching.
Again, I'm young.
I'm 15, something like that, thinking,
"I don't get all of this, but I like it."
Do you know what I mean?
Like, there were things
that you were saying
that I was like, "I don't
know what that reference is,
"but I kinda liked it", 'cause I was like,
"other people are laughing,
"so there must be something here."
- It's not the Warren Commission, brother.
(Dave laughing)
At some point,
the rhythms of it are intoxicating.
I just remember thinking, "Lean into this.
"If you're gonna rat a tat tat,
"you're working that speed
bag, you can't miss it."
I got the words down, I delivered them,
and I remember thinking,
"If they don't get
"the actual content of this,
do the d'Artagnan thing.
"Flourish."
You know?
- Yeah.
- Boom.
You don't always have to prick
the other guy's chest plate.
But you at least gotta stand out there
and have the blade twang.
I was always making sure
the right blade twanged.
Ba-boom!
- God, that's so funny
to me, to now, I'd like to go back
and watch some of them now
and sort of unpack a little of that.
- Yeah, you can't half stick that.
- Yeah.
- And I always knew
it was a bit of a scam.
- Yeah.
- Listen, I'm not, what I have
on my board's like 10, 20.
I'm not, like I said,
I could remember things
and get to them quickly.
And then I was smart enough to think,
"You can't half ass this.
"Sheepish is the death of this."
You've gotta lean into it.
And then I used to always
love Carson's moves when he--
- Yeah, yeah.
- Johnny Blue One,
or it wasn't there.
I used to find that intoxicating.
I would think, "Look how debonair"--
- Just the little head movement, little-
- Smooth.
I used to sit at home, I didn't
even know what showbiz was,
and I'd think, "Now, there's a cool cat."
It's in the moments where you
need to escape the bad one.
So that was another thing
I did on "Weekend Update".
I always remember thinking,
"Some of these are dogs.
"When it dies, a dog's death,
you gotta be alert enough
"to say that in front of the people,
"they'll find that intoxicating."
Like, you gotta look up and say,
no, I'm not so needy that my self esteem's
in your hands right now.
But I, too, know that was a bad joke.
- Yeah, but a lot of guys since you
have fallen into that crack.
- Well, what do you mean?
Tell me.
Do you mean guys looking
for applause and stuff?
Yeah.
- Yeah, when they know
it's not working, where
you would shake it,
I mean you would
literally, you just did it.
But you would sorta shake it off, kinda,
where they're kinda like, ah, please.
- Well--
- It's just the nature of it.
- I don't watch enough young,
there's a few cats I watch.
I think Maniscalco's like a stone.
Killer, I love his rhythms.
And Brian's a great,
Reagan's a great comedian.
But I don't watch enough
of the young guys.
I do know that at some point,
comedy almost turned into what
impressionists used to get.
Where you get applause.
I almost feel like, instead of you going,
Al Pacino working in a Burger King,
I think it would go something like this.
(Dave laughing)
I feel like guys
are doing that with their
political opinions now.
I think, and then they present it.
And you don't hear anybody laughing,
you just hear this.
(Dennis applauding)
And I was never into that.
- Yeah.
So even though I can sense
that Dennis Miller 2020
is slightly evolved out of, maybe,
the full grind and fight thing,
where are you sort of at, politically?
I asked you right before we started,
and it's like, you strike
as you're probably, mostly--
- I'm socially liberal.
- Yeah, you strike me
as mostly libertarian
kinda something like that.
- I come in, I meet your husband.
I can't believe there
are people in the world
who don't see people in love
and just be happy for 'em.
I see the picture of all these,
I don't wanna talk about your life--
- No you can.
- Your beautiful,
big family Walton Mountain
shot, everybody's smiling,
you two guys are at the center of it.
I don't know if it's your wedding day
or whatever that is.
- Yeah, it's wedding day.
- And I'm thinking, "How do
you get to the point in life
"where you're going up
to strangers and saying,
"here's what I think about that."
(Dave laughing)
That amazes me
that there's that, so
that part of Conservatism.
And I'm not putting
them, I know there's some
Christian people who think they
go to hell if they sanction.
I'm not gonna get, I'm not their shrink,
I'm can't get into their
life and figure all that out.
I just know I'm a believer,
and I've never had a chat with
my God about homosexuality.
It just, it didn't--
- It never came up.
- In my thing.
- It never came up, huh?
- And I met enough fervent
believers who are homosexual,
I think, "What, does God say
I can't talk to you today?
"You're gay."
So that whole thing doesn't exist for me.
I don't trust radical Islam
as far as I can throw it.
I'd like to keep half my money.
Some people think that's
a piggish statement,
but I always think--
- Boy, you greedy bastard.
- Yeah, but I think, "I'll keep one."
I give you one, I don't even know you.
And then people say, and
after I pay taxes on it,
I'd like to keep it for my kids.
And then they go, why do
you wanna spoil your kids
with an inheritance?
And I go, hey, why do the fuck
do I wanna spoil your kids?
I don't even know your kids!
At least I got joy outta my kids.
It's pretty simple stuff.
I feel like I'm a pragmatist.
But in today's world, man, if you're not
in lockstep, you're painted as,
Christ, I've seen pictures
of myself on the web
with a Hitler 'stache and all that.
- Oh yeah.
- And I think,
"I can't spend time worrying about that."
Those people are so reactionary
that the only thing, the
only way I can let them
into my life is if I let them ding me.
I don't give a shit.
I'm more than willing to seek
the approbation of strangers.
It's the human condition.
But only if it's worth it.
And I get a pretty good spidey sense.
I can tell early on, do I even need
to know this person anymore?
You meet some people,
within five minutes you go, too strident.
I'm still willing to make
these calls for myself.
Sorry, I'm in my own control tower.
I gotta get, I can't accept every plane
that wants to put it on the deck.
I gotta pick.
And I could tell pretty quickly.
And if somebody's amenable
just to be open-minded,
I don't even need to agree
with them on politics,
any of that shit.
Are they kind enough?
Are they a decent enough soul?
A good family person?
That's a big thing with me.
Funny?
Do they make me laugh?
So I got my criteria.
One of 'em's not being dovetailed
with their political beliefs.
But I see one side of
it, I see it as the left.
I don't even know, I think
you're making some journey
or something, I've always
heard your liberal.
And maybe if I--
- I think I'm an
old school liberal.
I think that's basically what you are.
In you believe people--
- Socially.
- Should be free, and even
on the economics stuff.
An old school liberal
didn't want high taxes.
You actually wanted low taxes.
- Yeah, Jack Kennedy
would be decried today.
- Yeah, JFK.
- Yeah.
Knocks the top rate down
from 70 to high 30s.
Christ, can you imagine Bernie
Sanders weighting into him?
And this Kennedy kid!
(both laughing)
But--
- Is that crazy to you--
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- How some really bad ideas
have started to become
seemingly normal now?
- Any time you see kids looking up
at Bernie Sanders in the same way you see
those young girls at the
Sullivan Show looking
at the Beatles, the world's
gone horribly askew.
I see those kids like, and I think,
"Are you kidding me?
"This is the guy we
used to avoid his lawn,
"'cause nobody knew if he
had buckshot loaded up."
All of a sudden he's swoonable.
It makes me laugh.
Bernie Sanders can't
believe he's pulled it off.
- What do you think the
obsession with politics is?
Like, that kind of thing.
- School loans.
- You think that's it
more than anything else?
- Listen, man, when you get to a point,
and for kids, I know they're
gonna talk about health care,
but by and large, I don't
think kids in their 20s,
and they're always so
invincible are thinking,
I'm gonna have a goiter when I'm 70.
Is it gonna be covered?
I don't think they work that way.
I do think a lot of kids are
getting out of college now
with north of 100 or high 10s school loan.
They can't even get off
the pad in their 80s.
It's almost like they're
working with loan sharks.
They gotta pay that off before
they can get to their dreams.
Therefore, they think, "Fuck my dreams".
I'm not gonna have a house.
I'm gonna live in a small micro apartment.
I'm not gonna get a car.
I'm gonna bike around or pick up
one of these jerk off
scooters on every corner,
and I'm gonna go out once
a week with my friends
and film a Michelob
commercial where we're all
sitting around and we're
all putting our beer
on top of a turntable.
And I'm gonna pay for
a great glass of wine,
because I don't have any options
on getting a house or a car.
And I think all that's happening is,
if I was a kid and I was sitting there
with 100 grand worth of school loans,
and it was for an
environmental studies degree,
where quite frankly I
went out and they said,
here's some dish washing solution.
Go clean that dove up on the beach.
I'd be saying, who's the guy
who wants to forgive my loan?
I'd probably be going there.
But I'm not anymore.
I'm the old guy who had
minimal school loans,
paid 'em off, and they
can't expect me to go back
and see it that way.
I don't wanna give up
everything for people who,
if I was telling a kid right now, I'd say,
brother unless, brother and sister,
unless there's a super
serious thing you can
get a degree in that you can exchange
for green rectangles, don't go.
'Cause half the people going in right now
are getting degrees that mean nothing.
And you could have four
years on the ground.
Find out what you want, get in there.
Get into whatever the
equivalent of the mail room is.
Spend those four years, Jesus,
for God's sakes, you'll have 1,500 days
while they're sitting
in there holding seances
and stuff like this,
where you can be out there
building a resume where the boss goes,
that kid busts his ass.
So when the college kid gets
out and comes in you go,
I've got a degree.
I was in student government.
And the guy has to
pretend, well, that's good
because he doesn't wanna
end up in a lawsuit.
He's thinking, "I got
this kid busting his ass
"for four years, I'm
gonna give him the gig."
So I think politics right
now for young people
come down to school loans.
- What do you think of the other guy.
We've spoke for 40 minutes
and still haven't said--
- Who, Biden?
- No, the T word.
Oh, we could do Biden.
Let's do Biden.
Where you at with Biden?
We didn't talk about Trump
yet, it's been 40 minutes.
Legally, we have to.
- Well, let's do Biden first.
- Yeah, let's do Biden.
- Listen, I've always made fun of Biden.
I think he's, anybody who gets in at 29
and is now 77 is inviting guys like me
to make fun of 'em.
I know he's helping me.
Joe, I don't need your help.
Live your life.
- Is he helping you?
How is he helping you?
- Well, he always talks about
how I've been in public service.
And you just wanna say,
oh for Christ's sake.
Okay, yeah, thanks for helping.
But I don't dig guys who get off,
who quite frankly get off
their old man's nickel
onto the public dime in their late 20s
and ride it all the way.
It always bored me with Jerry Brown.
He's pitching himself
as an ethereal creature
and I always think, "Brother, you've been
"on the teat for like"--
- Forever.
- "You're in your sixth decade now, okay?"
So don't tell me about
what a freeform you are.
But Biden has never been as
smart as they told me he was,
or he told you he was.
Anybody who knows their
IQ is a big tell for me.
Two things.
When a guy you're golfing with goes
into the woods and you get to the green,
you go, what'd you get,
and he pulls his hand up,
I know he's fucking with you.
And whenever a guy says, I
know my IQ, I go, "oh, Christ".
I don't like that to begin with.
I go, why?
Why do you know your IQ?
Are you that insecure or
are you faking it that much?
Biden's one of those guys
who knows his own IQ.
And I never saw him as a genius.
I always think of Joe
Biden as the third guy
in a car in a Sonic commercial,
just popping up in the backseat,
and I like the tater tots, too!
So he's no genius.
But now he looks addled.
I have more trouble--
- Yeah, what do you
think of that?
I mean, something is seriously wrong.
- Well, he had some sort of
subdermal hematoma years ago,
right?
- Yeah, but it's only
in the last, he had that
something like 20 years ago.
- He's 77, he's off his feet.
They're gonna push him ahead.
He might get elected.
I'll tell you what, he'll never go
on a debate stage with Trump.
He'll never do that.
I can hear the whole thing.
They'll put it on the prompter for him.
He'll go, I will not normalize this man
by being on the same stage with him.
It would be beneath my dignity,
but more importantly, more impoignantly
beneath the dignity of
the American people.
And he'll get all tied up and poignantly,
and end up in a straight
jacket, they won't even know.
They'll have to come out
and get him off stage.
But they'd vote him in 'caus
they hate Trump that much.
I think he's by the boards.
I don't think he was all
that much to begin with.
I don't like back slappers,
I don't like glad handers,
I don't like that core
and plume bullshit about
I walked through the diner today,
and you find out the diner
hasn't been there in 20 years.
Biden just never impressed me.
To me he's always been more unhinged
than a rescue dog in Phil Spector's house.
- (laughs) So before we
get to the Trump guy,
do you think a good
person, like, actually,
like, sort of an enlightened
decent human being
could ever be part of this thing?
It seems like the ship has
pretty much sailed on that.
- Yeah, I'm trying to think of--
- Although, I think a great
reckoning could be coming,
maybe, to our whole political system.
- Yeah, but it'll be so cataclysmic,
it remains, to me, unimaginable.
- Yeah, no, I think it is unimaginable.
I don't know if it'll be '29
where all of a sudden the Dow,
it's happening now because of the virus,
but I'm just saying, it'll either be 1929
or 1860-something like that, unimaginable.
You don't wanna be the first guy in saying
I can see a civil war coming.
They'll make you out to be the bad guy.
But seriously, for the
reset that happened now,
I don't see it being incremental.
I see something, just this
shy of cataclysmic happening.
Maybe corona is it, I don't know.
But if anybody thinks the
dems are gonna solve corona
after what I just saw in
their own caucuses in Iowa,
I don't know that I wanna
hand it off to them.
But I don't see it coming back around.
I see it getting very tribal.
And I can only hope at some point
we divvy up the albums like
a relationship that's gone.
It's like Woody Allen and Annie Hall.
We got a dead shark here.
Is that what he used to say?
- Yeah, yeah.
- And what we got here is a dead shark.
And divvy the albums up.
- So what does that mean, though?
What does that actually mean?
Like, what does that look like?
We divvy up the albums, meaning what?
We're in--
- We should split up,
in my mind.
I don't see it coming back around.
I don't know how to do that.
- That doesn't work out
very well for guys like me and
you in California, you know?
- You move.
I don't even know if it's geographic.
I don't know what I'm saying.
People are, exactly.
(Dave laughing)
I'm telling you I think
at this point, we got a dead shark,
and I don't quite know
how we figure it out,
but at some point we shouldn't try
to go closer together,
'cause that's only gonna
make it more anchorous.
We don't get along, we don't even agree.
I tell you, one thing I do notice
is I find people, I've been on the right
and I've been on the left
as far as issues in my life.
I've also been thought
of as somebody who's
on the left and then on the
right, mistakenly over my life.
I find the left is really
more brutal than the right.
I mean, I used to tear people
in the conservative
community a new asshole
when I'd meet 'em.
They could at least laugh about it.
The left, man, it can get dangerous.
You know.
You're gonna catch a D sale on a tube sock
if you don't agree.
And so that's why I zip it periodically.
- Were you kinda shocked, though,
when you first started seeing that?
Like, you first go on
"O'Reilly" maybe you have this--
- Nah, I wasn't.
Mort Sahl wrote a great book
years ago called "Heartland".
- Ah, I need to read it.
- And I think when people
think back on Mort Sahl they always
think of him as liberal.
Probably because he was Sancho Panza,
or Boswelled at Kennedy's Jack,
well, what am I thinking?
Boswell's Sam Johnson to
Kennedy's Sam Johnson.
He was his chronicler.
And he liked being in
the, with the cool kids.
But he started to see it,
and he started talking about liberalism.
And he was a real hipster, Mort.
I don't even know if
Mort's still up there,
or maybe he's passed.
- No, no, he's still alive.
Unless something happened
in the last week.
I'm 99% sure he's still alive.
- And I just started
having that epiphany.
I remember what happened with Stockdale.
I remember everybody's
making fun of Stockdale.
And I think McCain had
told me once that Stockdale
when he was in the Hanoi Hilton,
when kids had given up and they
were gonna kill themselves,
he would get on the pipe at night
and tap it with a flint to pray with them
in sign language to convince
them not to die that night.
- Wow.
- Like, something that maybe,
what, 1,000 men in the
history of the planet
have been consequential enough to do.
And then he's on cable and he goes,
"I don't even know why I am here."
- Why I'm up here.
- And everybody
makes him an asshole.
And I thought, "This room's
gotten too hip for me, man."
If we're gonna start, like
talking about Stockdale,
like he's an idiot, and Nancy
Pelosi's a viable player,
I just thought, I can't be in the libs.
They ask too much of the lockstep.
- Yeah, you think the
Republicans have any sort of
more functional people this day?
- I have found out, but I
can only speak for myself.
Like I said, I've poked a
lot of fun at conservatives.
And I've met some who've hated my guts,
and I've met others who at
least laughed about it a little.
That's just my experience.
I have the people on the left
do not take a joke as well.
I think that's kinda, I don't think I'm
saying anything sacrilegious there.
I think a lot of people are noticing that.
Guess what nobody wants to say.
- I hear you, Miller.
It's been my life.
- You don't wanna end up
in the crosshairs of that.
It gets ugly, man.
- So what do you think
of that Trump guy?
- Well, listen.
I'll say this about Donald Trump.
I think his outer voice,
as crazy as it can be,
is an entirely accurate
depiction of his inner voice.
Whereas, I don't think somebody
like Hilary Clinton's
inner voice and outer voice
have ever even had a
cup of coffee together.
Listen, there are days I look
at Trump and I'm mortified.
I think, "God, can't you just shut up?"
but I don't spend every day of my life,
because it's just as tedious to say,
we should quit tweeting.
I hear people that's what
they wake up in the morning,
what they, he's not gonna quit tweeting.
He doesn't drink, so lighten up, assholes
is his Cognac before bed.
That's what he does.
But do I think he's done some good things?
Yeah, I do.
Do I think he's done some things
that aren't panning out now?
The kid's firing missiles
again in North Korea?
I don't know, he might have
to smoke him at some point.
But do I think meeting
with him's a bad idea?
No, I don't.
Do I see Obama when
he's in there having a,
leaning in and saying, tell
Vladimir I'll have more leeway
to talk to him.
This all goes on, we should be talking.
It's just that Obama
never got outed for it.
They even had the tape of him.
It's like DeLoreon
selling blow in the room
and he somehow gets out.
The guy's on tape, Joe Biden's on tape
doing the thing they accused Trump.
I can't do it anymore, it's stilly.
Do I think Donald Trump's perfect?
No, he's a boarish cat.
I like the way his kids are.
They seem loyal to him,
they seem to be raised
to be somewhat discipled.
There are days he goes
after people and I think,
"Brother, that is so
thin-skinned, I can't believe it."
Are there other days I
think, "Wow, good for you."
When I see a union guy in the oval office
with a hard hat on
crying 'cause his old man
came here from Ireland
and he would be proud.
Beautiful stuff.
I'm not gonna play the game
where I think he's Hitler.
To me, when they do that
Hitler thing I always say,
well, what do you mean he's Hitler?
I go, you mean you fear
he's gonna croak six million
of his fellow humans?
And they always say, no,
of course I don't mean that
and act like you're an asshole.
- Right, right.
- Oh, what other
Hitler peccadillo were you talking about?
The bad stash.
- Bad artists.
- The Angie's List reviews
for house painting?
What are you talking about?
- Yeah, well, I think
you're basically right.
I mean, they say these things about him.
But is there a piece
of him that strikes you
as very much, like, he
has the mind of a comic?
Because I saw him live--
- He's got good timing, yeah.
- I saw him live in December,
and he goes up there,
and he's got the prompter, but he's also
winging it half the time,
and he's ad libbing and everything.
And he did this thing about,
he was talking about windmills.
And he goes, he goes, I've
been studying windmills
my whole life.
Nobody knows more about windmills than me.
And then he starts rifling off some stats
about windmills that were
obviously on the prompter.
And I turned to David and I was like,
you know that the headline
in "Politico" today
is gonna be Donald
Trump says he knows more
about windmills than anyone,
which he obviously meant as a joke.
And then lo and behold,
we see all the headlines,
Buzzfeed, blah, blah, blah,
and it's like, I think
that's his greatest gift.
He knows how to punk
these guys every time.
- Yeah, he's a wind up--
- Whether you like it or not.
- But that's the, I can't
even do that with him anymore.
Everybody talks about Trump now.
Notice how many times the word,
whether you like him or not comes up.
That's all of us laying
covering fire down.
I don't like him some days.
But it about more trivial shit than some
of the stuff he's doing which matters.
But I think some of the things he's doing
as far as the, when somebody
comes to me and say,
says that the black
unemployment rate's down
to its lowest ever, and
somebody immediately goes,
Obama started, okay I'll
give Obama credit for that.
I'm gonna give him credit
for getting it down
a little lower.
I just can't play this stupid game
where he's the antichrist.
For God sakes, there are days I feel
that he's super adept at his job.
There are other times I think
he's super thin-skinned.
There are days I think about
his comedy chops are beautiful.
There are other days I find it buffoonish
that he would waste time punching down
to somebody that's
stupid on the other side.
He's the human condition to me.
All I know is this.
I don't see the country
being over as they do.
I don't.
This corona virus is yet another thing.
They're gonna say the country's over.
I guess I'm a half full guy.
Do I think that,
occasionally do I see Trump
as half full of it or half empty?
Yeah, I guess I do.
There are other days
I look at him and say,
good for you, I wouldn't
take that shit, either.
Imagine the maelstrom this guy is in
on a day-to-day basis, him and his wife.
And when people say, oh
he was mean in a tweet,
I go, yeah, punch him back.
- What do you think
about the way we just go
from that crisis to crisis?
- I won't do it anymore.
- Yeah, you just, yeah.
- I'm gonna ask
for a week off between vaping,
a billion creatures killed in
Australia, and coronavirus.
- Net neutrality killed
half the people I know.
- (laughing) It's too hysterical.
I don't wanna live that way.
And if people find that harsh,
I don't know what to say.
I do know this.
I saw the corona virus figure for today,
and people say, oh,
you're so simple minded.
It's obviously 10 times more.
I guess I am stupid.
When I read an article
that says we've lost
around 10,000 people this flu season,
and we've lost 30 for coronavirus,
and then the end of that
article is that experts say,
thus the coronavirus
is 10 times more lethal
than the flu, I go, "Okay,
I guess I'm too stupid
"to follow that."
It's like when they used to
have the unemployment rate
would go, when more people were
employed and it would go up,
you know what I mean, and they'd say,
well, there are less
people in the workforce.
- There are less people in the workforce.
That's a big one.
- And so I can't
follow that, either.
- Yeah, more people
have selected out of the workforce,
so the number--
- I'm more than willing
to concede I'm not as smart
as somebody like Behar.
And I just, I'm not.
They figured out I don't.
- Wait, Ben who?
- Behar.
- Joy Behar?
- I see her quoted a lot and I think,
"I wish I could keep up."
- I used to love her.
- She's a cool dame.
- No, I'm sure she is.
- It's just that I guarantee
you, Joy's hip enough
that when she gets left
to her own devices,
even she's bemused that she's treated
like she's speaking in encyclical.
(Dave laughing)
And she's a great comic.
And she's found a great gig.
And I know she's liberal,
but I'm just saying,
when I see people now as
being the source material,
I just like sorta laugh.
I'm more than willing
to concede on around,
let me say, 60% of the world issues,
I'm guessing, like most people are.
And the other 40 seem set in stone.
They just seem, you don't put 15 billion
on a pallet and fly it
into the Iranian desert.
If you can't see that,
you're missing the point.
- So bad move, you're saying.
- Yeah,
at least give 'em a check
and in the memo section,
to liquidate Israel.
- (laughs) Right,
but instead we just--
- Cash, no here,
go use this, what are you guys gonna do?
You're canning this season?
- Trust us, trust us.
- Christ.
- What's else
is kinda interesting to you these days?
- Let me see.
What have I been doing?
Well, as I said, I'm trying to read a lot.
And I'm reading voraciously.
And I hike, I go walking
almost three times a week
with my friend, Jimmy
Connors, the tennis great.
- Oh, wow.
- And he's a bit
of a pisser, and he lives near me.
- I saw him on a plane about a year ago.
We were waiting to get on.
I went up to him and I
mentioned that crazy year,
what was it, like '94--
- Yeah, where he went
102 and three.
- Yeah, and he kinda smiled
at me and he nodded.
It was like ah, I was just that guy
that I mentioned that one thing.
- Well, let me tell you this.
Everybody talks about Federer
and he's obviously, I think
Jimmy would even probably say
the greatest player ever
because of the majors.
But to this day, in the
open tennis tournament,
Roger Federer is around 30 matches,
wins, behind Jimmy, who's in the one slot.
And he's around six
tournaments behind Jimmy.
And Jimmy never beats that drum, man.
And when I go hike, I'll go,
"Jimmy, why did you never tell me this?"
So I looked it up, and
he'll go, ah, fuck that.
And he'll right away start
talking about other things.
So--
- Just the joy
that that guy played with.
I mean, ah.
- The alawn.
I don't know, there's a fine line there.
Jimmy was never a happy time out there.
He was a stone killer.
And guess what?
In a world of tepid, in a world
where everybody's figuring out how
to explain somebody's missteps
before you get to them,
to have a guy who's an
honest arbiter of his legacy
tells you where he screwed
up, or he tells me at least,
tells me where he did well
and lets the numbers speak
and doesn't beat the drum.
He's a mensch.
I like that stuff about people.
And there's too many altruistic people
with publicists nowadays.
Imagine selflessness being shepherded
down a red carpet by Rogers Zencowen.
Hey, this guy did something
that nobody's supposed
to know about, can we
get a team over here?
I don't think that.
- Here's the wing
he just named after himself.
- (laughs) Right.
- I feel like we're there.
- All right, brother.
- I feel like I got, like,
a full on thing from you.
I wasn't exactly sure.
I got a little bit of a different thing
than I was expecting, actually.
It's kinda cool.
- Well, you're pretty easy, man.
Thanks for letting me talk.
And I'm glad you're doing so well.
I'm glad you're happy, man.
- Things are all right.
- Did you ever read the
great Tom Wolfe book,
well I liked it, I don't know
if a lot of people called it
"A Man in Full", and it was a book,
well, you'd have to read it.
It's about a man reaches
a point in his life
where if he feels he's a man in full,
indeed he very well could be.
And that's not defined as
you classically define it
when you're a kid.
It just has to come a moment
where you just sit there
and there's no static.
And you just say, it's not even exultant,
it's not triumphant,
it's just kinda quiet.
And you think, wow, I feel
like a man in full right now.
The frabba jabba in my
head's letting down a little.
- You know what?
I've never read the book, but I do love
Frank Sinatra's "My Way",
and I think that's kind of--
- Exactly.
Although Frank didn't think of the song.
- Is that right?
- Yeah.
Paul Anka wrote it.
And Frank, it wasn't his cup of tea.
- It's just so perfect.
- Listen, when you're
the chairman, you don't wanna have to be,
regrets, I've have, I
don't know that Frank,
except to sell millions of copies,
I don't know that Frank's gonna go out
and introspect in front of strangers.
But did I ever tell you my Sinatra story?
- No, tell me your Sinatra story.
End this with Sinatra.
- Okay.
This is a cool story.
I'm in Vegas one night
and Tom Dreesen calls me,
the great Chicago comedian.
He's opened for Sinatra
down at the Desert Inn,
which isn't even there anymore.
That's how long ago this was.
I'm up at the MGM Grand and he says,
"Listen, I'm opening up for Frank tonight,
"and you wanna come
down and see the show?"
And I go, "Yeah."
I said, "What if we're
working at the same time?"
He's already checked, we're offset.
Come down after your show.
I go down to see Sinatra.
Dreesen says, "I'll leave you
as many tickets as you want."
Now, I'm in town with my wife,
who's pregnant with our second child,
and our baby, our Filipino nanny, Coi-Coi,
and my mom's with me, and me.
I do the show, I go back to collect them.
My wife says, "I don't wanna
go, I don't feel up to it.
"I feel sick and I'm gonna stay in."
I go, I got three tickets,
why don't I take Coi-Coi,
'cause I hear in her room
at night listening to
Sinatra once in awhile.
She says, "Great idea."
Off we go.
The nanny, my mom, and I,
we go down to see Sinatra.
It's a revelation for me.
And he's not on top of his game.
He's a bit in a disdain of
one, but it's still fab.
He's Sinatra.
Frank Junior, I'm thinking,
I'm knee deep in it.
I go back to thank Dreesen after the show
and he says, unbelievable.
He says, "Hey, Frank dug you on 'SNL'.
"You wanna have dinner?"
I go, are you kidding me?
We go to that old restaurant
in the Desert Inn.
It was an Italian place and it had a gold,
cheap gold elevator, circular.
You'd go up and you'd go in
and there'd be the bar,
and then the main room,
and then the VIP room, then the VVIP room,
then the Pope room, and way
in the kernel of the nuclei
is the Sinatra room.
We go all the way back,
Dreesen opens the door,
there's a table, it's pretty small
and there's like 10 people.
And there sits Sinatra
right across from me.
Barbara, his wife sits
here, his attorney is here,
his attorney's wife, over his shoulder,
two huge Luca Brasi body guards.
- Of course.
- Dreesen sits here,
and my mom sits here, I
sit across from Sinatra,
Coi-Coi, the nanny's sitting here.
And around 10 minutes in I realize they're
being so nice to us.
They think Coi-Coi's my wife.
And I don't wanna shut it down and say,
no, no it's my nanny.
I figured I'll just roll with this.
So I start getting shit faced.
I'm not a big drinker, but I'm thinking,
"I'm with Sinatra, I'm
putting something on cubes
"and I'm gonna tinkle the glass."
He's talking about a fight he
had at Mr. Kelly's in Chicago.
I'm thinking, "Christ, I'm in 'Oceans 11'.
"This is the greatest
night of my", so I toss it.
And then we're having fun.
And then Coi-Coi nudges
me under the table,
and I look down and she's got
an autograph book on her lap.
And she motioning.
And I panic.
I can't say anything,
so I have to go complete body language.
I look up and I'm locked
eyes with Sinatra.
He's looking at me.
He thinks I'm having a grand mal seizure.
(Dave laughing)
He thinks I'm a freak,
so I have to flatten out and go tabla ras,
so I'm just sitting there,
but now it's hanging
over my head like the
autograph book of Damocles.
So around an hour in I go,
see we gotta blow 'cause
I'm too nervous now.
Go around the table, now
here's how cool Frank is.
My mom goes up first.
She said, "Mr. Sinatra, when
I was a young girl, 1952,
"I saw you at the Stanley
Theater in Pittsburgh
"and had dinner with you.
It was the biggest thrill of my life."
Sinatra looks up he says,
"'52, Stanley Theater
"in Pittsburgh, I
remember that show, baby.
"You were on the left side of the stage,
"you looked good that night.
"You looked really good.
- Ah, he's good.
- My mom, like floats away
like a "Ferngully" fairy.
I'm all chocked up.
I step in, I go, Frank,
gees, what you just did
for my mother.
He gives me the Jilly Rousseau
face slap, get outta here.
I turned, Coi-Coi steps up, whap,
she hits him with the autograph book.
I almost pass out.
I got the cold sweat.
And I hear Sinatra over my shoulder say,
"Did you say Soy-Soy?"
(both laughing)
And the body guard says,
"Coi-Coi, Frank, Coi-Coi."
And Sinatra actually says, "K, C, what?"
I can't even listen anymore.
I split.
They come out there flying in tandem
like the Blue Angels now.
I can't get mad of her,
she just came from Manila,
we're at dinner with
Sinatra, she's in shock.
I go, gees, Coi-Coi, let me see it.
I open up to the page he
signs, it says, "To Sopo".
It's like he went so far but
said fuck it, I'm trying.
Here, here's your Sinatra name, dear Sopo.
Best night.
- And you called her Sopo
from that day forward.
- Well, later on I went up
when she got married, to her golf club,
and people were coming up and going,
so you know Sopo?
So the story lived on for her.
And she was the sweetest soul.
- Miller, it's been an absolute--
- All right, man.
- Absolute pleasure.
- Good talking.
- Oh, you're walking out
in the middle.
I'm gonna say goodbye over here.
Sit down.
- Oh, I'm sorry.
I've been talking for like four hours.
- Gees.
Yeah, my God, it was a lot of talking.
Follow this guy, @dennisdz on Twitter.
If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check out our
full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.